I think if I may about his degrees they
have to be quite honest they have messed
up the economy quite substantially and
although they have been given very very
substantial held by primarily the euro
countries but also by IMF the quarterly
by the UK and Sweden there are question
marks whether the present government is
really either willing or able to do what
is necessary to sort out the situation
that's tragic for everyone primarily for
Greece but if there is a eurozone
breakdown involving Greece will it
affect you think Britain or indeed
Sweden particularly adversely not
necessarily but of course we all in
Europe and and Greece is a partner
country the one way or the other we all
of the country we'd like them to be able
to sort out these problems and we like
to be able to help the euro countries
does help the IMF does help but at the
end of the day they'll have to do it
themselves but but i think is things if
things go is very wrong it's got to be
primarily sorry to say a major problem
for the Greeks do you think David
Cameron is wise at this early stage of
British negotiations to say I know I
won't get treaty change I think it's
been fairly obvious for a long time and
I think that shouldn't come to surprise
to as a surprise to anyone that sort of
a big treaty change is not going to
happen with that that particular time
period and and I think is good to
recognize that and then I think it's
more appropriate both from the UK and
from the wider european point of view to
focus on the issues of substance of
reform that could be there where the lot
of the agenda that has been pressed by
the UK over the last few years has now
been mainstream again day in europe but
there are other issues that now needs to
be addressed and i think there's a
constructive will to sort them out
whether it will succeed let's see is it
a problem for the european union now
that frankly political leaders are
afraid to have a treaty change on
anything because it needs ratification
in sovereign Parliament's governmental
Parliament's which are likely it's
rejected or indeed in those countries
where they have a referendum they're
also like to vote no it's very difficult
to see how constitutionally Europe can
never move forward well you can argue
that and that there's a substantial
element of that and but at the same time
I I do think that one should be very
very careful with treaty changes i mean
we change the constitution in sweden
every day i don't know it could take a
hundred years until we do it so that
that is the big framework that you
should not change that often and we have
the lisbon treaty which is in 47 this is
what five six years by now and i think
virtually everything that needs to be
done it can be done within that and then
you can make other legally and
politically binding commitments of
different sorts on the side of that or
outside it on top of it but i think why
should be careful with constitutional
changes in countries and treaty changes
in europe what about the freedom of
movement of people within europe because
of the migration crisis is pretty clear
that that is unpopular in individual
countries can anything be done about it
well i mean may make the difference
between sort of EU citizens and the
migration crisis that we're having no
the migration crisis is a very major one
and i think it's fairly obvious we
listen to that now that there will have
to be some sort of solution that is
common we need to work together on that
there's not a UK or in Italian a sweetie
solution would have to do together as to
the principal's inside the single market
I mean the fundamentals of the second
market is there's a free movement of
goods of services of capital of ideas
and of people and I think that's very
difficult to change then there could be
elements of benefits and other things
that one could indeed one should look
into without discriminate against each
other but can countries like Britain or
indeed Sweden where people
all want to go to even from within the
EU particularly from Eastern Europe can
they absorb tens if not hundreds of
thousands of workers coming in each year
well I mean long-term we we need more
people as a matter of fact we have a
demographic deficit in Europe but but I
mean the speed and the pace that we are
seeing now is of course problematic I'm
a Sweden is taking if we take a per
capita I think we are taking roughly
eight times as many as any other EU
country and I cornea there is a need to
share out the burdens of somewhat that
is why it's important for the leaders to
sit down as they are doing as we speak
to try to move this issue forward is
going to be very difficult but it's
going to be even more difficult if they
don't do it together because this
pressure is coming from outside of
Europe and it's likely to is more likely
to increase than decrease in the years
to come even in politics a long time
what's your guess five years time are
greased and Britain's still members of
the EU yes ok believe you there thank
you very much addy